[Música]
en españa las empleadas domésticas
representan el 4 por ciento del total de
los empleos la cifra más alta de europa
análisis hace parte de ellas hace 27
años se fue de república dominicana
hacia españa
el objetivo ayudar económicamente a su
familia
para quiénes
mucho dinero porque te digo que haremos
alemán 230 euros aquí dice 30 euros
rinde mucho al cambio allí hay mucho
dinero
cuando llegó estaba en una situación
migratoria regular
empecé a trabajar empleada del hogar
porque la única forma para poder salir
adelante para poder tener tus papeles
entonces me dieron de alta
después de 18 años trabajando este caso
al igual que muchas empleadas domésticas
soporto muchos abusos horas implementar
jazz no remuneradas para los atrasados
no inferiores al salario mínimo legal
no está incluida en el régimen general
de la seguridad social es el sector más
precarizado de este país yo pienso que
se aprovecha de esa situación que la
mayoría de las mujeres que trabajan en
este sector son migrantes
al igual que anne lise 80% de las
empleadas domésticas son de origen
latinoamericano
la asociación sedoac fue creada para
defender los derechos de la profesión
hoy se presenta una obra de teatro que
denuncia su explotación
por ley le corresponde dinero por mes
trabajado
un sueño
y con todo lo que hemos hecho porque
todavía tienes esas vacaciones no señor
no señor
estas mujeres exigen los mismos derechos
para su sector que para cualquier otra
profesión tal como le explica carolina
la presidenta de la asociación las
empleadas del hogar
exigimos derecho a la prestación por
desempleo cotizar por nuestros salarios
reales inspecciones de trabajo efectivas
entre las 700.000 empleadas domésticas
en españa más del 40% no estarían
declaradas obligadas a vivir en la
precariedad muchas dependen de la ayuda
alimentaria distribuida por algunas
asociaciones
estas dos amigas están en una situación
migratoria irregular desde hace dos años
como lo necesitaba pues había que
aceptarlo se habló de que eran cinco
horas 500 euros pero que son cinco horas
donde usted quiere quedarse en la casa
completa con héctor se viven los finos
de sobrevivir
que realmente es algo que a veces tienes
que pagar servicios
con menos de 16 euros al día se
encuentran en una situación de pobreza
extrema al igual que un sexto de las
empleadas domésticas eras empleada de
casa si perdiste tu trabajo así cada día
el presidente de esta fundación se
encuentra con decenas de estas mujeres
antes de la pandemia les pagaban diez
euros la hora
ahora no hace más que bajar son siete o
cinco euros ahora ellas no tienen opción
deben trabajar
es la nueva esclavitud del siglo 21
una precariedad que las lleva a aceptar
cualquier oferta de trabajo adriana
peruana trabaja como interna de la
pandemia la familia que la emplea nunca
la dejaba salir por miedo al virus
de 14 meses 12 meses he estado encerrada
interna porque mi trabajo ya interna
está a disposición permanente de la
familia para todas las tareas y vive con
ellos un trabajo inmenso sin pausas en
el exterior
me sentía como en una cárcel
llegó un momento en que quise abrir y
que la puerta y no regresar y caminar y
caminar
no valió de nada de que yo también soy
un ser humano y de que también
necesitaba salir siquiera la esquina y
regresar
estar encerrada no fue fácil sobre todo
si de sí en el dentro del trabajo
no había humanidad para mí
son mi galería también hizo un gran
sacrificio se fue de paraguay y dejó
atrás a su familia hace 15 años para
encontrar un trabajo como empleada
doméstica
y nada mi sobrino que no le he visto a
crecer a ninguno son todos ahora ya son
todos mayores con su trabajo pudo pagar
los estudios de sus hijos pero nunca los
vio crecer
es como un abandono sin querer pero es
un abandono al fin de tantos años de
estar lejos de ellos entonces casi no
nos conocemos porque toda su
adolescencia ellos crecieron solo
con la pandemia redujeron su tiempo de
trabajo y también su salario un
detonante para ella me di cuenta de que
aunque ellos te digan que eres parte de
la familia que eres importante cuando a
ellos les toca una parte importante de
su vida crecer el dinero entonces
nosotros prácticamente nos quedamos a un
lado como para hacer a principios de
julio quería tomar a sus maletas para un
vuelo solo de ida en dirección a
paraguay